remarkably individuals showed an average
decrease in biological age of eight
years
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video we'll
break down a recent paper that has given
us a first look at some data of human
patients taking regiment and
alpha-ketoglutarate-based formulation
whereby they assess their biological age
by using the dna methylation clock
so in this video we'll break this paper
down completely address exactly what the
data shows what it doesn't show and what
i think the take-homes are so firstly
what is alpha-ketoglutarate
well alpha-ketoglutarate otherwise known
as akg
my students would probably know very
well as being a key intermediate in the
krebs cycle which is important for
aerobic respiration
so this is important for burning glucose
fats and proteins to generate the
reducing power to make atp the energy
source of the cell
however akg is more than just a
component of the krebs cycle
it can also be used by the body as a
precursor to amino acid production amino
acids being the building blocks of
different proteins
as well as acting as a cofactor for
different enzymes in the body
it was previously shown in a study that
akg supplementation increases the
lifespan of the worm c elegans and i
reported on a study that came out last
year showing that the calcium salt of
akg extended both the lifespan and
health span of mice
so given that akg is generally
recognized as safe
the company that sponsored this latter
study ponce de leon health wanted to
test it for human aging so this brings
us on to this recent publication that
has already caused a lot of excitement
on different social media platforms
so what exactly did they do
well in the study they had the
participants taking regiment which is a
product that's currently being sold by
the company that sponsored the previous
research that have a sustained released
version of a calcium salt of
alpha-ketoglutarate
and that source of akg is combined with
a specific vitamin depending on the sex
of the participants
so for females they take it along with
vitamin d and for males they take it
with vitamin a
and so the dose that they were taking
were two tablets per day which meant
that one dose contained one gram of
calcium alpha-ketoglutarate
in terms of who and how many people were
in this study you can see the data
summarized here so in total there are 42
participants one-third but females and
two-thirds were males and their ages
ranged from 41 to 79 years with a mean
age of 63
all were healthy without any chronic
medical conditions
and each participant was taking regiment
on average for seven months
so what were they assessing in the study
well the only measurement that they took
was dna methylation that was detected by
sequencing once they took some saliva
samples from the participants at
baseline so before they started taking
the product and on average after seven
months after the participants were
taking the measurements
so what does this mean well dna
methylation is a epigenetic mark so it's
a mark that's found on top of your dna
sequence
in this case it refers to a cytosine
residue so cytosine being one of the
four bases found in dna that can get
methylated and so you can use a
sequencing approach to detect either the
presence or absence of methylation and
then what's been done more recently and
pioneered particularly by steve holvath
is to use these measurements and predict
based on whether or not there is a
methylation mark or not
the chronological age of the participant
and so this kind of inferred
chronological age is also referred to as
a biological age
there are many different types of
epigenetic clocks currently available
but the one that they used in this paper
is based on this true age prediction
model and that only needs nine of these
methylation sites
and so by having less sites that also
does make it a bit cheaper for them to
perform this test
now as you can see in this figure here
they first tested whether or not this
correlated with the participant's
chronological age and you can see a
positive correlation too and so
effectively here they were validating
the use of this model
so what happened after they took akg
well on average they saw that the dna
methylation age decreased by 8.31 years
by the end of the period and you can see
the data summarized in this figure here
and so the y axis here is showing
chronological age minus the true age
epigenetic predicted age so if the
number is bigger than zero then the
predicted biological age is younger than
your actual chronological age
so in general most of the lines trend up
between before and after suggesting that
the biological age has reduced following
the treatment
you'll notice that not all the lines
trend up and the amount of change also
varies but on average this was 8.31
years
now importantly because the relevant
supplement varies between males and
females they also look specifically at
the sex-specific changes and so in both
cases they also do see a decrease in the
epigenetic age
suggesting that it's more likely to be
the akg than the fertility differences
a few other things worth pointing out
with this data is that only two
individuals actually showed a slight
increase in their political age one male
and one female
and also it's interesting to note that
even though some of the participants
were taking this supplement for
different time periods there was no
correlation with the magnitude of the
effect
and so this may suggest that over a
longer period of time the benefits may
be saturated with supplementation
so this seems like exciting news so is
it time to all start taking akg well
whilst the data hit is very exciting i
have to say there are a few points i
want to make
firstly it's important to note that this
is not placebo controlled so all the
participants here were taking akg and
they knew that they were taking it
and so some of this benefit could
literally just be due to placebo
secondly it was a short-term study and
it would still be important to
characterize long-term effects of taking
the supplements
but another really important thing to
stress is that the only thing that they
measured was this dna methylation age
there are no other clinical markers
given in this publication neither is
there any functional measurements
and so it would be hard to say exactly
what akg could be doing to the body and
whether this actually refers as more
functional aspects of aging
and so this brings me on to more talking
about this dna methylation because
firstly it would have been interested to
at least validate this with other
methylation clocks and also because at
the moment the association between these
different sites of methylation and the
aging process are still a bit unclear
and then lastly i guess it's worth
mentioning that the company behind this
paper are trying to sell their products
commercially and say i guess that's kind
of a big disclaimer and the data that
they might present
so all in all whilst i think this data
is very encouraging i think it's
important to realize that this paper
doesn't provide definitive proof of the
so-called fountain of youth but i will
keep you posted as we learn more
information
and whether or not we can see this data
translated through to randomized
controlled clinical trials
so with that i hope you plan to make in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening
you